most head-mounted virtual reality
displays have a horizontal field of view
of around 100 degrees which pales in
comparison to the human visual field of
more than 180 degrees
this makes the VR experience more akin
to looking through binoculars limiting
the sense of presence in the virtual
scene
we present the concept of sparse
peripheral displays which augment the
field of view of a head-mounted display
with a low resolution low weight and
expensively produced array of LEDs
around the central high resolution
display our virtual reality prototype
called sparse light VR extends the
standard oculus rift dk2 prototype with
a set of 70 peripheral LEDs creating a
170 degree horizontal field of view
we also implemented an augmented reality
version called sparse light AR which is
built upon a custom modified galaxy gear
VR prototype
sparse light AR is an untethered device
which extends the horizontal field of
view with 112 peripheral LEDs creating a
190 degree horizontal field of view
sparse peripheral displays provide
additional contextual information
increasing the situational awareness of
the person wearing the display
to render the color of each led we
design a series of matching light probes
that can be deployed in any Unity game
engine scene
using sports like VR we conducted to
user experiments to evaluate the
effectiveness of sparse peripheral
displays in the first experiment we
compared the participants performance in
a simple search tasks on three
conditions using a narrow 50 degree of
field of view similar to most automatic
reality devices
using a standard 100 degree field of
view oculus rift dk2 virtual reality
headset
and using a 170° a sparse light vr
hybrid display in our visual search
tasks the sparse light VR display
significantly outperformed the lower
field of view displays
our second experiment investigated the
effects of different visualization
schemes in the periphery and their
effect on simulator sickness the task
required the users to follow an orb in
the scene using a controller
we compared an unmodified oculus rift
dk2 setup with our sparse light VR setup
configured to render an extended field
of view
we also compared a novel visualization
called peripheral counter vection motion
which creates a motion effect in the
periphery opposing any motion that does
not directly originate from the person's
head motion
11 out of 14 participants indicated that
the peripheral counter vection motion
visualization reduces the effects of
similar sickness in our task and both
sparse light VR conditions were
preferred to the standalone rift display
please see the paper for more details in
summary our sparse peripheral displays
are an inexpensive lightweight solution
to extend the field of view of a
head-mounted display and can increase
presence and reduce the effects of
simulator sickness